Matt Walsh drama he got he got majorly
hacked 20 years of his personal emails
he also is leaving YouTube after they
demonetize him hopefully his impact is
not so I I overall like the message that
Matt Walsh uh uses he's he's very
tradcon left or sorry right-leaning you
know conservative uh guy uh marriage big
family blah blah which is all you know
good and fine but
I think he misses you know quite a few
things his documentary what is a woman
on daily wire is actually quite good I'd
I'd recommend watching it if you can uh
find it or just you know subscribe to
daily wire to watch that because I think
it's a
it's a well-documented perspective of
what's happening in the modern world so
this is what happens when you stand up
against the woke mob right this is this
is what happened to guys like Andrew
Tate you know that's why they put him in
jail I mean they haven't even charged
him he's still under house arrest for
another 30 days did you guys hear that
he's under house arrest
well I did a conversation yesterday
about Escaping The Matrix and I think it
was a Caleb Jones idea where like you'll
never really escape the matrix the idea
is to get plus the idea is to get
plugged onto more grids so you can skip
grids but we saw the entertain thing he
talks about the Matrix well he's
technically in The Matrix he can't I
mean he can't leave his damn house right
now yeah
um so Matt Walsh got hacked and you know
this is what they'll do if they don't
like you you know there's some there's
some geek somewhere that may not like me
that um you know could could do
something nefarious like this
um it's just weird dude like you know
you've
you can't say things for somebody asked
me on a podcast the other week
um
British guy I can't remember the name of
the podcast right now I've done so many
podcast interviews
um but uh you know the question was like
do we have free speech
and if you had free speech you could
express your opinion without any
consequence but there's always
consequences to express in your opinions
and Views and whether it's suppressed or
repressed or you're demonetized by a
platform like YouTube like that's how
YouTube typically handles it if they
don't like what you have to say or they
think that you know what you're saying
doesn't align with their corporate goals
they'll just take your ability away to
make money
for my stuff I just I just went to
rumble like three days ago I get twice
as many views on Rumble as I do YouTube
and I've been at YouTube for like a year
and a half yeah so so that's what
they'll do and you know fortunately if
you're if you're big enough you'll find
a way to survive it like Andrew Tate
will be fine Matt Walsh will be fine
um you know there's there's always fans
for stuff like that but that's how they
respond in a childish fashion you know
they you know
the old saying goes and I quote it in my
book a few times you know if you have a
problem with the the facts the problem
isn't with the facts and I S and I think
that guys like Matt Walsh generally
speaking speak the facts right he just
happens to Target a community
um you know the trans groups
um the alphabet crowd and all that and
they just fire back because that's what
they do I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the
full-length podcast you can find that
over here that clips from if you're new
to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out